that's a gun jeschica
we don't the really annoys [ __ ] cause
I'm gonna use action bong joon-ho is a
filmmaker obsessed with rhythm you can
sense it in all of his films but in his
latest parasite he outdoes himself the
tempo is perfectly calibrated as a
viewer it almost feels like you're
surfing the story the way the editing
and camerawork sound design and music
carries you from moment to moment
I think bong knows that getting the
pacing exactly right is the only way he
can get his bold tonal shifts to work
the result of such attention to rhythm
is a totally immersive viewing
experience the cadence of the whole
movie is tightly controlled but there's
a montage about 40 minutes in that
distills his mastery into a perfect
diamond of a sequence 60 shots almost
exactly five minutes definitely my
favorite five minutes of the year and I
think it's worth taking a closer look at
because it's really a thing of beauty
first the setup the montage comes at the
end of Act one of parasite after a poor
family have almost successfully duped a
rich family into hiring them all for
service jobs the son becomes a tutor the
daughter becomes an art teacher the
father a driver and other attempting to
bring the mother in as a housekeeper
problem is that the existing housekeeper
is well established and well liked by
the rich family so the poor family
hatches a plan to remove her from the
picture it's a great idea to enact this
plan in montage because we've already
seen three successful cons at this point
the tempo slowly building in each with a
montage the cutting will get even faster
and bong can bring the entire act to a
crescendo also as the poor family's
plans get more sophisticated it's only
right that the filmmaking does as well a
montage like this is going to test your
ability to convey a lot of information
across a limited number of shots in this
case 60 let's take a look at the first
few
hanging on from guru run their opinion
is Honiton grania Waterton Salman even
Sarah a twisted Shiva
[Music]
cuckoo cribs havin do Tom trophic
receiver such a door doesn't go too
crazy
well the Kogi's held on crew could to
work a contra cut under something crazy
kangaroo hot lava could carry yours a
tiny car would cause a huge bang engines
in his element saw cars [ __ ]
Christian wear boxers and couvent a easy
call it Sumatra Naja Monica City on
criminals chief juniper gun and a car
don't belong back in case come on Tony
tell him to cool on the cloud Quran
desert Juanita man hold it up on watch
from Atlanta but you carry he sad thing
the first thing I notice is how balletic
everything is helped along by a
classical piece from Handel's rohtul
into opera the pacing is mesmeric bong
achieves this by selectively using both
slow motion and linear camera moves
every shot offers a piece of information
several foreshadow later moments in the
montage and this referencing back and
forth as well as the camera moves and
the music all contribute to making the
sequence into an organism all its own h1
a montage is a sequence that manipulates
time look how many shots it takes to get
from idea to execution chronica talent
is hidden by mm cosmo swallows you a
little caramel cremeux good hotel in
Detroit honor Kotori token channel adore
movie same package go Hokulani
trans here to sing that liquor and a
name
[Music]
bond gets from the moment the Sun hears
about the housekeeper's allergy to the
moment he poisons her in eight
economical shots
that's conciseness worthy of Hitchcock
who bung actually snuck into this
montage a few shots back the poor father
is deceiving the rich mother so bond
shows him literally taking her for a
ride
he sets the pace and she follows him but
there's actually another level of
control here because the words he says
were written by his son who designed
this duplicitous
little play to get in there
[Music]
do you Iike oh I was its young conjoin
Oh mom you're even in the Akutan the
Ayakashi from naraku's hell at this
point it's probably a good idea to bring
up bongs editor Jin mo yang who
obviously had a major role in shaping
this sequence and the whole film now
bong does a lot of the editing himself
by extensively storyboarding but any
editor will tell you that the rhythm of
a scene comes down to my new adjustments
and sometimes you have to get creative
if you look at this shot for example
frame by frame you can see something
strange right here in the middle of this
pan yang stitched together two different
shots because neither individually has
the perfect pacing from both actors so
he Frankenstein's it to get the right
tempo Cody Johnson correct Pancham bada
Tahoe so not waking back hanging down
there I mean when I say I'm using to
quantify cell yang also had a big part
in finessing this section of the montage
which originally had much more
repetition of the lines yang intercut
the locations to give the tempo more
bounce and as a result it feels like a
single conversation which actually
reinforces the conversation this montage
is already having with itself a
conversation that is about to pay off
[Music]
this montage is a testament to bong Joon
hos control of his craft but it's also
about control it comes at the moment in
the story when the poor family's cunning
their ability to control things has
reached its pinnacle their plan was as
perfect as the sequence and it went off
just as smoothly but as we and the
family quickly discover even the most
airtight plans are vulnerable to events
success often contains the seeds of a
later downfall especially when it was
achieved by means of cruelty in act 2
the bottom falls out narrative Li and
literally and this montage is cast in a
new light the plan was not as perfect as
it seemed which of course makes the
montage even more so hey everybody
happy holidays Happy New Year happy
decade thank you so much for watching
this episode was brought to you by
Squarespace
if you don't know you can use
Squarespace to make beautiful websites
for anything you might need a personal
site a wedding website a site for your
business or portfolio and in just a few
clicks you can have that website up and
running their design team has crafted
really amazing templates that work on
computer browsers and on mobile
switching perfectly between the two you
can integrate your own photos and videos
just a few clicks and you can even link
your social accounts so that you can
Auto post to Twitter and Facebook all
from within Squarespace and over to
Squarespace comm for a free trial when
you're ready to launch and go to
squarespace.com slash nerdwriter for 10%
off your first purchase thanks again
guys I will see you in the next decade